My name is Gregor Mendel, and I think
I can explain what Hypocrites' blending inheritance model cannot.
>> Okay how's that?
>> Well, as a monk, I have quite a bit of quiet time, so I did some breeding
experiments with pea plants that were published in 1866,
which I think have some serious implications on human traits.
>> Well, what was your model called?
>> I call it Particulate inheritance.
Particulate inheritance means that characteristics can
be passed down from generation to generation through
individual units. I believe you call them genes nowadays?
>> Wow! I can't believe you figured all that out using just pea plants!
>> Why does everybody doubt the pea plants? Think about organisms collection
of genes, being more like a deck of cards rather than a pail
of paint. A red and white paint can be mixed and the result
would be pink, but passing that down, you'll never get true red again.
Genes are more like cards, that can be sorted and
passed along, generation after generation in an undiluted form. Sometimes,
the cards can be covered up so that they don't
appear at all until they're passed down to the following generation.
>> That's a pretty clever description. Which
of the following examples do you think
can be explained by particulate, but not
blended inheritance? Check all the boxes that apply.